folks if you're a TV junkie like me
you're excited it's a big thing tonight
is the season premiere of NBC's this is
us that's the show with people I I love
this is us but I mean like everybody I
mean the show makes me cry a lot
ya know me to remember it was that
episode when Jack I'm I'm sorry no it's
okay you know I I know what episode
you're talking about and it's it's a
tearjerker
I mean the one that gets me is the one
where Rebecca she finds out I'm sorry
who just said boohoo twas I who booed
and who'd you Conan and twill be I who
does it again right now
why are you bowling because very soon
your precious little weep fest this is
us we'll really have something to cry
about as it is torn asunder by my
favorite show
okay well based on your outfit it's
pretty obvious what your favorite show
is a show where the mighty and devious
battled for supremacy in a world of
sorcery and fire yeah now I add Vyasa do
hear that to hear the moan of the frigid
frosty wind something is coming Conan
and it starts with a W yes your time a
game of Thrones and you're a fan and
winter is coming we get winter nay I am
speaking of wall burgers
whoa burgers wait the reality show about
Mark Wahlberg's family running a burger
joint in Boston that's the show you're
talking about yes indeed that is the
wall burgers of which I speak amongst
all the tales ever told none compares to
the epic saga of Clan Wahlberg and their
never-ending quest to argue while
cooking beef okay
I'm sorry and I'm shocked the whole
crowd went along with you on this one I
haven't checked that show out but isn't
it just a sounds awful I'm sorry yes it
is awful as in full of aw as in flip aw
and wonder as in ah I wonder what it's
like to cook cheeseburgers if your
brother is Mark Wahlberg okay wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute was
everything to watch on TV you are not
gonna convince me to watch wall burgers
and I'm sorry apology not accepted
by Crom Conan just listen to these
amazing storylines from wall burgers
there's the episode when when Donnie
doesn't or enough beef patties here's
patty I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
don't care about Wahlburgers storylines
I really don't well the one where the
health inspector
I'm sorry wall burgers is a very sad
show okay would you sir
sir please get a hold of yourself all
right I know what might change your mind
what if you could taste a wall burgers
burger right now
sure you know now he mentioned it I
guess I'd be up for a wall burgers
burger right now sure great do you have
one no wait why would I have a wall
burgers hamburger lying around good
point Conan O'Brien then will have to
cook some it's time for a cooking
segment
[Applause]
[Music]
no I am I am NOT I am not letting you
cook burgers on my show that's not gonna
happen
oh I'm not cooking burgers my Eagles
Brad and Amy are Oh Brad Oh Amy
alright alright fine the audience seems
to want this what do we what do we do
how does this work
Brad pay me cook Conan oh well burgers
burger okay oh for God's sake that's
they're just dropping dead animals into
the pan I don't even think these Eagles
know how to cook I'm beginning to agree
with you Conan oh my god where did that
wolf come from the wolf smells the dead
animals Brad and Amy will defend you oh
never mind that's just their friend Kyle
wait a minute you're saying the wolf's
name is Kyle yep oh no that's terrible
[Applause]
so sad this has been another
tear-jerking episode of street is caught
such a sad show I've had it I've
completely had it I don't want to hear
any more about wall burgers or anything
I want you out of my studio and I want
you out now fine I can take a hint
Wahlberg is just too good for your show
anyway Brad Amy Kyle let's get out of
here
[Applause]
[Music]
he's carrying the whoa and now he sets
the wolf down at the top great
you